autre actualité de cette journée cette
cérémonie aux allures d'union sacrée qui
s'est déroulée il ya quelques instants
la synagogue de la victoire à paris il
s'agit vous le savez de rendre hommage
au jeune ilan halimi enlevé torturé et
tué notamment parce qu'il était juif
c'est en tout cas une des pistes
retenues par la justice fait
exceptionnel
jacques chirac assisté à cette cérémonie
ainsi que de nombreuses personnalités
jf vite imbert frédérick basile c'est
une cérémonie religieuse
ce soir le kaddish la prière dite après
un décès devaient être lus pour ilan
halimi avant un discours du grand rabbin
sitruk un moment religieux donc même si
dans la synagogue de la rue de la
victoire à paris
l'hommage va bien au delà de la
communauté juive le président de la
république arrive peu avant 19 heures
accompagné de son épouse jacques chirac
avait téléphoné à la mer dylan
avant-hier dominique de villepin est
également présent ce matin le premier
ministre confirmait le premier
l'arrestation de youssouf fofana
gilles de robien catherine colonna de
nombreux ministres sont là aux aussi en
fait la droite et la gauche sont réunis
ce soir de ségolène royal à dominique
strauss kahn mais aussi françois
hollande de françois bayrou à philippe
de villiers beaucoup d'autres à
l'extérieur comme à l'intérieur ils
disent les mêmes mots indignation et
solidarité
c'est un acte de solidarité à la garde
d'une famille qui a été touché dans sa
chair
c'est aussi un acte de solidarité à
l'égard des juifs de france qui se
sentent concernés par ce crime odieux
ce que nous avons vécu nous voir plus
revoir les déclaration de manifestation
c'est bien mais plaide pour des vers et
au delà union sacrée des politiques etc
humanisme des religieux monseigneur
andré vingt-trois archevêque de paris
assistent à la cérémonie tout comme
dalil boubakeur
au nom des musulmans de france c'est
donc en tant que musulman bien sûr venus
apporter et mon réconfort ma compassion
partager la peine de la famille à
laquelle je pense très fort et en
particulier à la maman de
malheureuse victime jivan la synagogue
de la rue de la victoire peut accueillir
1500 personnes dans les rues alentour
plusieurs milliers d'autres sont
rassemblés ce soir à la mémoire d'ilan
halimi
oui le